ora pulso ao de 2011 mais um vídeo e
hoje vou ensinar como fazer uma peça da
ilha com tambor
vocês pediram bastando por fazer um
revólver só que eu deveria dar um pique
nesse projeto porque ainda não conseguir
destinar um gatilho e como eu gostaria
mesmo de fazer um revólver com gatilho
não percebem fazer uma cadeira e talvez
alguém de uma ideia como eu vou
conseguir por um gatilho e pronto caso
vocês não têm idéia de vou tentar mesmo
encaixar um detalhe é isso então pronto
hoje vou ensinar como fazer considera
estar mas tenho que me dê força então
vocês devem deve e tem mesmo que usar
óculos de proteção se vocês não tiverem
podem usar óculos de sol que é a mesma
coisa que é importante ter alguma coisa
a frente cara pra curtir os vossos olhos
e claro não vou andar e pará contra
ninguém é sejam responsáveis e que
estava com mais definição e era mostrar
corrida por uma questão de orientação
para vocês ok é vocês já vão perceber
melhor o primeiro tem que rolar uma
folha como se fosse uma rifa
se vocês não entenderam bem como fazer
esta rifa bem fininha eu vou deixar um
link de inscrição vocês vão lá e ver o
vídeo mais devagar para poderem fazer
quando é ser feliz um tutorial passo a
passo bastante simples porque vocês
pediu depois fazer e refazer e
impulsionar uma folha à volta dessa
rifam depois tem que ir lá mais uma
folha à volta da rifa e do primeiro
clube e vai de 1 cada para tem uma cor
de frente até então a idéia porque usei
de frente coisa que vou usar sempre a
mesma cor porto bem grande por tudo
intermédio e para risco a cair agora tem
que cortar segmento de cinco centímetros
são seis segmentos no youtube maior quer
que o branco
eu tenho que fazer uns cortes nele em
fazer este corte para todos o suposto 20
é muito importante que vocês fazem
estoque e eu pude tentar explicar por
que mas é melhor vocês verem mais para
frente não vou me engajar tudo vai
encurtar o o tubinho laranja seja o
segundo biênio é do mesmo um cumprimento
daquelas partes brancas e agora é só
colar a volta mas tenha em atenção
aquela piscina para ficou de fora que
você escutar uma parte de uma parte
ficou por fora vejam aqui tem que ficar
sempre colado ao tubo vanja cair é só
encaixar que os encaixa na perfeição se
vocês tiverem feito a rifa acontecer
porque é base de referência cair e isso
é muito importante vocês fazerem tudo
bem muito apertado e quando a volta era
uma coisa muito importante você tem que
usar uma cola rápida quer uma colega sua
capa uma cola forma uma super cola e tem
por a volta desses volta todos os
círculos e deixar secar não foi baseado
para novos tejo os tubinhos até e isso é
muito importante para dar resistência
agora quanto fazer esta parte tem as
medidas e leis escritas não cola só no
final do tubinho cai pois só enrolar
vocês quiserem no início quando for em
prol do vinho não vai chegar ao fim
porque cola vai ficar até o domingo
chegar outro lado caiu por uma cola
daquelas normais um carinho vocês podem
pôr mais o quê
vamos lá por cima é parte do cano e tem
20 não me engano é importante vocês
podem me foi passado foi o tambor e pelo
cano pra ficar tudo alinhado é muito
importante ficar tudo alinhado não pois
não vai dar
ele vai criar um atrito e vai ter a
força arma
veja que o puzzle mais um segmento
branco não por um segmento do início ao
fim mas não fica uma parte laranja tem
mesmo deixar essa parte do jockey e
agora vou fazer a coronha ganha bastante
simples
você já deve estar muito familiarizado
com ela o melhor por mais fita para
ficar tudo pro forçado é por que decola
prontas aguenta mas como uma folha está
enrolado em camadas é facilmente se pode
aprender agora está para ser a voz custo
só se você tiver alguma idéia de como eu
consigo possa encaixar um gatilho deixe
nos comentários que o garcia e quer
dizer na verdade vai ver o concurso
brevemente pronto vocês podem participar
mostrando como for um detido como fazer
um revólver aproveitando este sistema de
som do tambor é e claramente se vocês
conseguirem fazer estarão em grandes
é como dizer com grande probabilidade de
ganhar em um dos três prédios só por
cola na parte branca e laranja e é só
colar
agora tem que chutar uma rifa e dar isto
sem um contorno da arma para baixo pela
parte está a dar um murro for só cair
pode parecer que não mas ajuda bastante
na existência da arma por si só e quando
morre um grande beijo aqui é muito
importante
vejam que aquela parte laranja vai mesmo
em cima do tubinho passa o segmento
branco fica por baixo e é por isso que é
importante em um tambor assim o papel
fica livre de dispensas mas nem pensa em
ficar complicado e vejam que põe em sua
cola na parte branca e depois é só colar
agora pra ficar tudo alinhado leva uma
rifa é só orientar os três segmentos
veja onde acaba o partido laranja tem
ficaram com e se desculpar branco ac no
lado direito e agora é só fazer o pistão
marco viram que ele tem que ficar quando
comeu marcar e é basicamente a rifa azul
fica encostado ao tambor depois onde a
cabo para franja vocês marca está a usar
q2 elástico este lado da questão que
tenho mais forte do que o normal e não
são aqueles normais de escritório - a
quem levantará bastante a venda destes
uma bolinha assim muita gente pergunta
como eu consegui fazer uma bolinha de
elástico praticamente tudo bem já
e vejam que escola e também e nestas
partes aqui porque vocês não quiserem
cola que vai acontecer é que vai haver
muito atrito e também podem conseguir
parar só que o papel vai se machucar
todo dada a velocidade do pistão cair
muito importante vocês porém cola e
fazeres para tirar o chefe
para depois não não criar atritos
encontrar lá muita cola
então vai impedir o normal funcionamento
estão em que nesta parte também
e agora uma coisa muito importante desta
vez vou ensinar como fazer as balas
no último episódio não ensinei fazer mas
quando vocês ficaram sem saber como eu
fiz as balas basicamente vocês vão ver
aqui
essas não são as mesmas têm uma pequena
variação que permite que quando você
encaixar elas no tambor elas não saem no
rosto e ir para fora
quando cheguei em arma cair e vejam que
é sonho lá dá para ter maior para a
parte mais pequena
enquanto se fosse uma bola normal era só
vocês por aqui cola e colar tudo mas
como é por aqui no tambor
vejam que eu faça um corte e fica assim
maiquel como se fosse uma seta é inveja
quando você se encaixa que vai ficar
preso e não vai cair pra fora
depois é só encaixar as bolas e vejam
que ficava em uma partida sem bola
vocês vão encaixar o pistão
se vocês quiserem mais força é só dar um
nó nos elásticos mas convém não abusar
muito porque a marca pele pode não
aguentar com muita muita opção
agora é só encaixar o outro vai ver como
é o funcionamento para mudar é é um som
do tambor com o barril a roupa do tambor
relaxa por cima porque eu mantém todos
os segmentos alinhados aqui é muito
difícil
veja como é que o mundo através do
shopping estão puxando um elástico roda
caixão outro elástica fica tudo alinhado
coisa só de esperar não só os campos o
fim eu espero que tenham gostado e tem
conseguido fazer é que mais os teste com
arma 36 maior para vocês verem como é
que ela foi comporta em questão do força
tem estado boa agora a questão da prisão
vai diminuindo a distância uma vez que
ela banda bastante quando está o disparo
uma vez custam impulsionado por um
elástico é brevemente vai ver o concurso
que vai ser o vídeo números e senhas e
98 e lá eu vou explicar mais
detalhadamente o que é preciso fazer
para se habilitarem
ganhar um dos prêmios então isso aí só o
suspeito no estado
se vocês quiserem ajudar o canal é só
deixar um like se inscrevam para
acompanhar as próximas coisas que eu vou
fazer é isso então já que tinha